[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 y me acompaña en el estudio
Marta Moya Marta bienvenida buena mañana
de lunes Hoy estamos de celebración ya
primer año de director América 5 años de
Fernando 24 en español y vamos a empezar
Entonces esta revista de prensa Marta en
Italia donde la victoria de ultraderecha
Georgia melón y estaba hoy presente en
todas las portadas nacionales Y
empezamos con la estampa Buenos días
Raúl Así es Felicidades por estos cinco
años como decías victoria de George
meloni nada raro nada que se saliera del
guión la estampa titula este lunes
Italia gira a la derecha Victoria
histórica entre miles de incógnitas dice
que Georgia meloni y los Trozos de
vidrio bajo el techo de cristal En
referencia a esta victoria de la primera
mujer que probablemente va a ser primera
ministra Así es que hice la República la
República destaca el porcentaje de
fratellida Italia de hermanos de Italia
el partido de meloni y dice y sameloni
se toma Italia el editorial destaca una
nueva era populista y una cita de melón
y de ayer es la noche del rescate del
orgullo libero Marta El Líbero Bueno A
toda portada dice libres derrota de la
izquierda ahora le toca a ella el
tirreno el terreno es este periódico de
la Toscana italiana que este lunes
titula Italia a la derecha después de 80
años Boom de meloni leta el candidato
del partido democrático y salvini el
candidato de la liga es la hora de la
verdad
es bueno vamos ahora con la ultraderecha
también que está presente en la prensa
internacional alrededor de todo el mundo
Marta Así es Lemon en Francia titula en
Italia pictórica Victoria histórica de
la extrema derecha el editorial destaca
una nueva sombra para Europa melón y
tendrá que liderar una coalición con
aliados debilitados perrosconi y salvine
vamos a ver qué dice el de morgen de
Bélgica este periódico se plantea un
poco Cuál es la denominación que le
tenemos que dar a esta coalición porque
dice hasta qué punto es extremo el giro
a la derecha en Italia cada medio ha ido
bueno es definiendo derecha ultraderecha
derecha radical todavía estamos
pendientes de cómo se define esta
coalición que verdaderamente es muy a la
derecha vamos ahora a nuestra región en
Clarín de Argentina también lo destaca
la prensa latinoamericana El Clarín
titula un giro histórico George meloni
se impuso con una Clara ventaja estado
de Sao Paulo también
Brasil se destaca la derecha radical
gana en Italia vamos a cambiar de tema
ahora Marta Porque como avanzamos en
nuestro pues introducción al programa La
Prensa local internacional sigue siendo
la cobertura de las protestas se dirán
que ya cumple hoy 10 días y que dejan
numerosas víctimas mortales hablemos
alrededor de 41 personas por la
represión del Estado vamos a empezar con
Irán wire Así es Y él irán wire destaca
también el perfil de una de estas
Víctimas hadid nayafin de 20 años que
murió en una balacera por las
autoridades iraníes y se convirtió en
este nuevo símbolo de estas
manifestaciones como decías 10 días de
protesta numerosas víctimas todo empezó
con la muerte bajo custodia policial de
racha a mini Y bueno pues esta joven fue
asesinada con seis disparos de bala con
heridas en el corazón en el brazo y en
el cuello y bueno se ha convertido
también en un nuevo símbolo de estas
marchas históricas que dice Marta de
Liberación en Liberación en farcy y en
francés destaca mujer vida y Libertad
que es el lema de estas protestas y dice
a pesar de la represión la movilización
no decae en Irán lo que empezó como un
movimiento por los derechos de las
mujeres se convirtió en una revuelta
contra el régimen vamos con un artículo
de opinión del Washington post Así es
dice el Washington post que debe
aprender occidente de las protestas en
Irán y destaca este análisis de Karim
sachapur que occidente concretamente
Estados Unidos debería repensar su
política con Irán porque está muy
dispuesto a revivir ese acuerdo nuclear
de 2015 Pero quizá tendría que poner el
foco en el régimen del revolucionario
Racing Marta y esta ocasión también la
refleja hoy el periódico británico de
Times como una curiosa ilustración que
vamos a ver así es una caricatura del
mortem morland donde se ve pues a esta
mujer
en las barbas del presidente brahim
Racing y queriéndose cortar el pelo que
sin duda uno de los símbolos de estas de
estas revolución de las mujeres estos
últimos días una muy buena caricatura y
terminamos revista de prensa siendo ya
un repaso rápido por todas las portadas
de Colombia y Venezuela que ilustran lo
que va a ser el tema del día de nuestra
región la reapertura de la frontera
Colombo venezolana luego de siete años
hablamos una reapertura hasta el momento
del paso vehicular de comercial No
todavía no vehículos privados
destacamos dos portadas venezolanas dos
colombianas empezamos por la portada de
últimas noticias de Venezuela que dice
Venezuela y Colombia unen sus caminos a
partir de hoy se abren los pasos
fronterizos entre los dos países el
diario 2001 dice también hoy se reabre
el paso por carro a Colombia luego de 7
años y tres de cierre total vamos ahora
al lado colombiano como usted lo dijo el
heraldo El Heraldo dice se inicia una
nueva era en las relaciones bilaterales
con un saludo entre diplo a partir de
las 9 de aquí hora Bogotá veremos Cómo
se reabre esta frontera terrestre Y por
último como lo titula también como lo
reseño los periódicos más importantes de
Colombia El espectador Así es el
espectador periódico de referencia en
Colombia titula reapertura de la
frontera una noticia añorada por años
destaca que los comerciantes de ambos
lados de la línea el limítrofe están
esperanzados y optimistas y que los
chats de los comerciantes venezolanos
destacan estos días frases como el
Renacer de la frontera la Nueva Era de
la frontera una época de florecimiento y
una segunda oportunidad dice Además este
artículo del espectador que la meta del
gobierno de Petro el presidente
colombiano es que para el final de su
mandato en 2026 el comercio se reactive
con más de 4.500 millones de dólares
bueno Marta Muchísimas gracias por esta
revista de prensa del día de hoy lunes
mañana Por supuesto con más de revista
de prensa mañana Muchas gracias muchas
gracias a ti Marta nosotros